hello everyone and welcome to the second
match uh between hikaru nakamura and
being lyran from the 2020
chestable masters uh ding won the first
one and now hikaru needs to win the
second one to force
a third one so here uh six games have
already been played in the second match
and the result is still a tie and this
is now the armageddon game
and as hikaru has the white pieces it
was probably ding who was
who won the coin toss and he get got to
choose as hikaru pretty much
always chooses the black pieces so i do
i do think it was being the one
who chose the black pieces so it's
hikaru who has a minute more on the
clock but also he needs to win this game
otherwise he's out of the competition
and for ding it is enough to draw the
game
or win to to proceed to the semi-finals
so
let's see what happens he car with the
white pieces opens with knight to f3
uh so he goes for the r80 opening with
knight f6 e3 and the g6
uh so now preparing to fianchetto the
dark square bishop we have c4
and the bishop to g7 sorry about that we
have knight to c3
continuing development at some point the
d4 will be played with c5 now
controlling d4
but still just a d4 and here we have
captures and captures usually
white will capture with the e pawn uh
however that's the that's the main line
and hikaru needs to mix it up in order
to create some imbalances in the
position
uh so he can maybe maybe grab a full
point here so
ding just castles and the knight back to
c2 ah you are expecting knight to c6 and
you don't want any unnecessary traits so
knights to c6 with bishop to e2
and now there is one game in the
database where d6 was played but here we
have e6 by ding
and it is a new move so already as of
move eight we have a completely new game
uh we have e4 by hikaru freeing up this
diagonal for the dark square bishop and
also grabbing more control over
the d5 square so uh basically preventing
ding from pushing d5 but
that's what's uh funny about this game
that's exactly what being plays here
ding decides to sacrifice upon he says
okay your king is still in the center of
the board and i will probably be able to
win it back later
so he goes for d5 we have e captures e
captures
and now c captures on d5 winning that
pawn
knight to e7 now with a triple attack on
the pawn so you can always win it back
but now
knight's the e3 now he car also defends
it three times and he says
uh i'm just gonna continue defending
this pawn
so here a6 preparing b5 bishop b7 to go
after the pawn then maybe b4 to kick
away the knight
and the hikaru goes a4 he says nope uh
you are not
playing b5 here so b6 biting preparing
bishop to b7 to add another attacker to
the d5 pawn and here
bishop to f3 not rushing with castles
uh but adding another defender to the
pawn with bishop to b7
and now again not uh we're
worrying all that much about his king
safety hikaru goes for d6
and now he opens up a discovery to the
bishop here and also attacks the knight
and the problem is
uh if you go for trades then ecap d
captures an e7 just wins the game you
can trade queens with
check doesn't really matter yours your
bishop is still hanging and the rook is
under attack so once you save the rook
g captures and uh okay you can eliminate
the pawn but white is still up a piece
you you have an extra knight on the
board
so this is of course losing so ding has
to go for knight to c6 he has to get rid
of both threats by blocking uh
hikaru's light square bishop and now
hikaru finally castles while keeping the
pawn on d6 we have knights to a5 by ding
now again offering a trade of light
square bishops and he wants to recapture
with the knight and add another attacker
to the pawn here
so he carol trades with captures
captures and now knight to c for
again defending the pawn as uh you
cannot go b5 b5
square is nicely protected twice so uh
you cannot kick away the knight so ding
tries rook to c8 he goes after the
knight this way
but now queen to b3 and now he says okay
you can
have this pawn however i'm gonna i'm
gonna capture this pawn
and ding goes for it he goes for knight
captures not that knight
knight captures on d6 we have knight
captures on b6
and now just rook to b8 again pinning
hikaru's knight here with a5 defending
and now knight to d7 again with a triple
attack here
ding is uh really trying to win that
pawn back
so knight c to d5 defending the knight
once again
and here ding decides to trade you could
also just not
trade but ding ding doesn't think it's a
problem he he goes for it with knight
captures on b6
with a captures on b6 again giving
hikaru a pass pawn
and now you also have the a6 pawn which
is a target and you will also have to
worry about that so here dingo's knights
the f5 he wants to be able to bring the
knight to d4
with a tempo on the queen and then maybe
to e2 with check maybe you can do some
damage this way
uh so here hikaru not in a rush to
capture yet another pawn instead he goes
bishop to f4 just goes for some
development
we have knight to d4 attacking the queen
and now you have to be careful you don't
want to run into a fork like we already
mentioned something like this would be
very unfortunate
so queen to c for instead keeping an eye
on the e2 square not allowing knights to
e to check even
check and capturing the bishop would be
troublesome because the the rook is
under attack
so rook the b7 now you do have to move
it but now
rook ate the d1 and now there's a double
attack on the knight and of course you
would be very happy if you could grab
the knight and the bishop for the rook
so
uh rook to d7 uh ding says no problem uh
if you capture here i'm just gonna
capture uh well your knight and d5 uh so
here
uh bishop to c7 is definitely an option
you just kick away the queen from the d
file and you you are very happy with the
position
uh and this is exactly what uh hikaru
plays so bishop to c7
with queen to a8 again attacking the
knight so still
keeping this this threat but now knight
back to c3 by hikaru again
with with an attack here but now your
knight is no longer attacked on d5
and here it's a very hard uh position
for ding it's
very difficult to find a good move uh
ding played rook to c8
but it's simply not enough so feel free
to pause the video here
and win the final a game win the
armageddon game for hikaru while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting either
of the two winning moves uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
he carl played queen to a4 he wanted to
attack
the the rook this way and then this rook
has no way to go but also if you found
rook to e1 which is
not as straightforward that also wins
the game the point is black has no moves
and next movie you're just going to play
rookie 4 and win the game
uh since you're gonna finally win
material here the knight cannot move as
the rook here would be hanging
so black is left without any moves
however the movie carl played is also
winning uh just queen a4 you go after
the rook and this rook now has no
squares
uh these two squares are covered by the
bishop the d5 square is covered by the
knight
and uh you you don't have any in
any moves here if you go rook to e7 uh
it's not much better just rook captures
on d4 again
uh you will win the two pieces for uh
for the rook
and uh not not much for for black to do
here of course the position is
completely winning
one thing you could do after this
quinte4 you could give up
the exchange but it also doesn't work
because after pawn captures
your knight is still hanging you cannot
eliminate the past pawn so you'd have to
go back but then
white has knight to d5 and now uh
you keep your pass pawn on c7 and black
is just lost point is if you capture
with the knight then just 97 check picks
up the rook and the black is
uh well black is completely shattered
so after this queen to a4 move ding
resigned which means uh
the second match goes to hikaru nakamura
which also mean
means that there will be a third match
uh between the two of them in the
quarterfinals of the
2020 trustable masters to decide who
will proceed to the semifinals so we're
probably gonna cover
uh a few games uh from the third match
uh today or tomorrow uh so do stay tuned
for that
so uh once again i do hope you enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank
yaman akraf uh and anthony parks ryan
brahman
uh kevin dowden catherine and aaron
lavine for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the chest
bull masters 2020 checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day